one of the sadder symptoms of not having
been treated well in childhood is a
remarkable tolerance indeed an appetite
for not being treated entirely nicely by
Partners in adulthood as graduates of
Rocky pasts we are at high risk of
ending up recklessly passive around
Partners who don't appear to have too
much interest in our true needs or
aspirations where others would read a
sharp risk in such neglect we simply
sense normality where others would be
plotting an escape we settle in for the
long term where others would despair of
intransigence or meanness we see every
chance of being able to change a partner
so long as we keep quiet and
hope it can take an awfully long time
until we are in any position to realize
that all told the situation does appear
a little strange and somewhat
irrevocable able that it may not be
entirely to our advantage to be told
again and again that we are mad for
wanting greater gentleness or demanding
for seeking a deeper connection or crazy
for wondering why a partner spend so
much time on their phone or out drunk
with friends we could be compared to a
giant fish a tuna perhaps who's had its
fins cut off and lost any powers of
navigation so that it Bobs helplessly on
the current hoping against hope that it
will be taken somewhere nice but unable
to exert any influence on its
course the famous expression runs when
people show you who they are believe
them but it's hard to be very cleare
eyed about who is good and bad when you
happen to grow up with a heavy
disincentive to perceive certain awkward
truths about your own parents because
you were 5 years old trapped in a house
with them and love wasn't readily
available from anyone else our entire
perceptual mechanism may have been
Twisted as a result like an animal that
can't perceive certain frequencies of
light our emotional eyes may have grown
up unable to see difficult traits for
what they are coldness now just looks
like honorable absorption in more
important tasks sarcasm is read as wit
being belittled feels like care we're
always more likely to think of ourselves
as bad for failing to elicit kindness
from a fundamentally lovely person whom
we'll continue to adore and admire
despite one or two signs of trouble as
opposed to conceiving that we might have
fallen in with a
jerk we may be deep into our lives
before we decide we might have had
enough of suffering and start to be
curious about what kindness and presence
might feel like we may ever so slightly
determine that though our partner may be
using every ounce of their considerable
logic and charm to secure the status quo
they might in the end just be taking us
for a very long
ride we don't have to be here we are
astonishingly not five anymore if we're
not happy we can run we are free this is
what being an adult should always have
been about